[Música]
y en directo a nos vamos directos hasta
Buenos Aires la capital Argentina para
ahondar en la crisis de pérdida de valor
del peso argentino frente al llamado
dólar blue el cambio paralelo e ilegal
comúnmente utilizado por la población
roza los 500 pesos por dólar esto en
medio de una alta inflación y la caída
de las reservas que llevan a especular
con una caída Además del peso oficial
ahora el gobierno de Alberto Fernández
busca que el fondo monetario
internacional les dé más libertad para
poder intervenir en el mercado ilegal de
cambio natalio jaque puede deberse Esta
caída del cambio y cómo está afectando a
la gente en el día a día
Sí qué tal Buenas noches la verdad que
el gobierno señala por ejemplo factores
vinculados con operaciones de
financieras habla de la oposición habla
de la derecha queriendo mover los
mercados en un año electoral recordemos
que este año se elige presidente en
Argentina y eso tiene el lugar del país
en dificultades grandes Pero bueno Más
allá de eso esto genera muchísimas
preocupaciones muchísimas Preocupaciones
en una población que viene arrastrando
una inflación muy dura que viene
creciendo mes a mes y este indicador el
del dólar Blue si bien no es el dólar
más utilizado en la economía en
exportación en importación esos son
otros dólares con otros valores muy
distintos a este pero si es una suerte
de referencia que usa la población para
entender Dónde está parado Y cuánto vale
su dinero y en un contexto de altísimo
inflación si ve además que esta
referencia que está mirando día a día
también se dispara de esta manera genera
inseguridad genera angustia y genera
mucha incertidumbre sobre una base de
incertidumbre que ya estamos viviendo en
el país vinculada como te decía con la
inflación además importante en un año
electoral
no natalio y qué opciones ha planteado
el gobierno para solucionar el
incremento del precio del dólar ha
pensado por ejemplo en aliviar las
restricciones al acceso en el mercado
legal
bueno esa opción no es viable por lo
menos en lo que es el dólar oficial que
tiene una diferencia con este dólar blue
de más del 120% hoy en día Ese es de un
acceso muy limitado muy poca gente puede
acceder a él solo 200 dólares por mes
podría comprar eventualmente hay otros
dólares que son financieros que son de
acceso más libre no lo puede hacer
exactamente todo el mundo pero su valor
es más cercano al de Blue el gobierno no
está en condiciones de alimentar de
dólares
al país de modo que se puedan comprar
libremente Por eso existen las
restricciones no está esa opción si el
ministro de economía salió a decir que
usar todas sus herramientas disponibles
y vos mencionabas antes en la
presentación que hay una discusión con
el fondo monetario internacional para
poder intervenir si en los mercados
legales como estos dólares financieros
que mencionaba no quiero entrar muy en
detalle porque es complejo pero entrando
en esos mercados puede mover un poco los
números y tal vez ayudar a desacelerar
esta escalada del dólar en Argentina